my mom says when I was a baby I used to
sleep on her chest like with one side so
my head is not as perfectly dome shaped
as I think it should be we are gonna
have a sketch artist and I'm gonna
describe myself to him and he's gonna
you know make me beautiful on the paper
I skew a little more on the side of
cartoony I did caricature art in high
school a couple times so you know I'm
pretty set here
well I would describe myself I probably
I have like an oval-shaped face even
though I'm pretty tall my head still
seems a little large for my body just a
little bit I think I got a pretty
oval-shaped face but I'd like to think I
have a masculine jawline I also I
wouldn't say like I have it's kind of
like a butt chin but it's not like a
butt chin all the people in my gene pool
have sort of a Joe eNOS to our face it's
kind of like a baby miss to the nose and
the cheek like I definitely don't look
like a baby versus a 36 year old but
there's something sort of baby like my
ears they're not too large but they're
definitely not small they're kind of
just like little accessories on the head
eyebrows I don't know what to say what
shape they're and maybe like Archie I've
been told like I definitely have like
what wide eyes like people get lost in
my lips please favorite my subconscious
this with my lips is more about how they
functioned and about how they look my
cheeks I would say they're definitely up
they're not like chipmunk but they
definitely have someone volume to that
whatever like Clint Eastwood nose look
like that's probably my nose if you took
the rock and then you combine them with
Clint Eastwood and then maybe put like
some Will Smith yeah that's I wish I had
like a predominant jaw line that's
definitely just kind of like a straight
down into my chin my hair is just like a
flu foot do and it's a little like it
gets poofy you're on the side especially
on the sideburns although I just trimmed
those today a little bit because I got
self-conscious of them I don't think my
lips are thin I don't think that thick
I've been told that I have you know good
like full lips or whatever
all right here we go ha ha I ran with
that baby face yeah you're talking about
your anything you got it look like an
evil character from like a Pixar movie I
mean it's it's not bad I can see me I
put some there in there maybe yeah I'm
pretty impressed that's pretty accurate
you got you got the Clint Eastwood 5
o'clock going on there you know he got
the ear pierced you got the snapback
those eyebrows do look like my eyebrows
it's funny like the things that you like
have slight responses to get a little
bit more enhanced talking about yourself
it just it makes me feel a little bit
more self-conscious about myself because
I'm just like I don't people to think
like oh he's so like conceited and into
himself because I feel like I'm far from
it but then again everyone has those
days where they're feeling themselves
and they just want the world to know
because I feel like we should have that
balance and be allowed to do so